the maesters tell us that aegon came to
Westeros with Fire and Blood and
hammered six kingdoms into one
fire he undoubtedly brought as the kings
of the rock reach and iron Islands
learned aegon's own son maegor the cruel
was killed by the very Iron Throne his
father had forged if you believe the
tales if you don't then perhaps the
cruel is not a wise name for a king to
earn
Darren first of his name tried to finish
his ancestors work and bring Dawn into
the fold for his efforts he lost sixty
thousand men and his own life of 18
years
during the Great Targaryen civil war
known as the dance of the Dragons a king
and queen each vied for the throne
dividing their house and its dragons
against each other eventually the queen
was fed to her rival's Dragon while her
son watched and the Victorious King soon
died of his own wound and by the war's
end King's Landing was smashed cities
raised and sacked never to be rebuilt
and Dragons had faded from this world
you have to wait two years until the
next episode of House of the Dragon so
now is the perfect time for you to
listen to the audiobook on which house
of the Dragon is based and you can
listen to it now for free that's right
you can listen to Fire and Blood
audiobook for free it's a Targaryen
history book on which house of the
Dragon is based written by George R
Martin it goes from aegon's Conquest
until the end of the dance of the
Dragons which will also be the end of
House of the Dragon you can now listen
to it for free with horrible trial using
her link which you can find in the
description of this video all you have
to do is go to the description click the
link sign up for free audible trial and
choose Fire and Blood audiobook go and
listen to a long and Rich Targaryen
history including the current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
for centuries the king's God had been
the glory of the realm aegon the
Conqueror had established the old as his
personal Guardians after uniting
Westeros with Fire and Blood he knew
that some of his subjects wouldn't take
to Conquest and his dragons were no use
against knives in the dark no doubt
surrounding himself with the greatest
knights in Westeros made his rule more
palatable and less foreign as well
everyone in this Kingdom soon knew the
names and sung the songs of the king's
God I certainly did from my earliest
days
there was one kingsguard I forgot the
bastard's name who swore an oath to his
dying Targaryen King to Crown his
daughter after him the very night that
King died his kingsguard crowned the
King's son instead when an old man on
the small Council dared to protest this
honorable night opened his throat
bastard died in a very civil war he
started along with the old King's son
daughter and most of their dragons
and the kingsguard all that Duty and
honor and not enough brains to figure
out which Targaryen to give it to
twin brothers even ended up on opposite
sides died with tears on their cheeks as
they cut each other down
I suppose I should think that's tragic
but stupid men do stupid things every
day and nobody cries over them
as little more than a boy sir Kristen
Cole replaced the legendary siriam red
wine on the King's Guard and soon Rose
to Lord Commander but Knights only know
one way to settle disputes
when Prince aegon's father died so
Kristen slit the throat of an advisor
who objected to aegon's Ascension over
his aunt the anointed heir his actions
so pleased the new king aegon second of
his name that he appointed sir Kristen
as his hand in the ensuing Civil War
called the dance of dragons neither sir
Christian nor the king nor even the
Targaryen dragons would survive it
the Targaryen dynasty United the Seven
Kingdoms and lasted nearly three
centuries
it was a dynasty forged in fire sealed
in Blood and destroyed by Rebellion
the targaryens are blood of the Dragon
descended from the nobility of ancient
valyria a once Mighty Empire in the East
when the cataclysmic Doom laid waste of
valyria and its people the targaryens
survived having settled on the island
Fortress of Dragonstone years before
they remained there for a century until
the rise of
conqueror
instead of attempting to reclaim the
Eastern lands of his ancestors
aegon sailed West for the Seven Kingdoms
his sister's vicenia and rayness at his
side
to keep the Bloodlines pure aegon
continued the custom of his Valyrian
ancestors and took both of his sisters
to wife
together they came ashore on the eastern
coast of Westeros their blazen a dragon
with three heads representing aegon and
his Sister Wives
their words
Fire and Blood
while their host was small in comparison
to the armies of Westeros that awaited
them aegon and his sisters had a secret
weapon
the last of the dragons
he conquered every Kingdom saved Dawn
which eventually bowed to dargaryen rule
a century later
he had the swords of his enemies melted
down by the fiery breath of his Dragon
balerion the black dread and forged into
the iron throne
capital city of King's Landing was built
on the eastern coast where aegon and his
sisters first came ashore
and aegon ordered the construction of a
royal castle on its highest hill
the red keep
aegon built his castle of Red Rock to
remind people of the fires he'd roasted
his enemies in so whenever King's
Landing locked up they'd see the price
of defiance
he knew the first rule of Kings
only fear keeps men in line
fear and Punishment
then again
torture chambers are just so
private
better to punish your enemies where
everyone can see and remember
like the Targaryen who forced his nephew
to watch as he fed the boy's traitor
mother to a dragon
oh what I could do with a dragon
stories claim that the old way died
would her in the black and his sons at
harrenhal are ships and axes were no
match for aegon's Dragons so our
ancestors sped their steel into Fish
Hooks and our kingdom into Villages and
started telling the Red Tails around the
fire of how we used to be strong and how
one day would be so again
Generations later a young boy listened
to them Dolton Greyjoy the wild young
heir to Pike was rowing at five and
reeving a tin in the Basilisk Isles with
his uncle by 14 Dalton had sailed as far
as old geese
thought in a dozen battles and claimed
for soft wives in his 15th year the
adventures uncle's death and battle but
he took a dozen wounds and emerged from
the fight drench head to heal in blood
from that day forward
men called him the red Kraken during the
dance of dragons the red Kraken picked
the side that was fighting the
Lannisters and fell upon the westerlands
while the Lannisters were up at War
costly Rock itself proved too strong
once the lady of the castle bought its
Gates but the ironborn burned the
Lannister Fleet and sacked lanny's
support carrying off gold grain and
hundreds of women and girls including
Lord Lannister's favorite mistress and
all bastards the red Kraken now ruled
the sunset sea as his forebears had and
his long ships again brought the old way
to the coast of Westeros but then the
war ended and the mainland armies came
home
the Iron Throne commanded the red Kraken
to stop breathing and when he didn't a
mistress opened his throat as he slept
while his son squabbled the Lannister
sent their soldiers to the iron Islands
thousands of men women and children were
put to the sword
and scores of villages and hundreds of
long ships were put to the torch
the Glorious return to the old way had
lasted almost two years
in its time the dragon pit was a Marvel
of the world
full-grown Targaryen dragons nested
beneath its massive Dome and even on the
darkest nights the walls seemed to Glow
with the fire of the great beasts inside
as had the site's previous occupant the
sept of remembrance and maegor the cruel
blasted it with dragon fire during
morning prayers
screams of the dying men echoed through
King's Landing all day and a Paul of Ash
and smoke hung over the city for a week
but as it dissipated so too did the
rebellion of the faith militant
the sept of remembrance faded from
memory and maegor decided to replace a
monument to the gods with a monument to
his family the dragon pit
labor proved elusive however for after
the red keep was finished maegor had
hosted a three-day Feast for all the
builders stonemasons and Carpenters who
had worked to build it at its conclusion
he slaughtered them so that only he
would know the Castle's secrets
so many men fled the construction of the
Dragon pit that maegor was forced to
employ the prisoners of the city
dungeons supplemented by skilled and
ignorant Builders from across the narrow
sea
for more than a century the targaryens
housed their dragons in the dragon pit
the dragons are not horses to be stabled
or hounds to be candled
with each generation the dragons became
less less massive less Swift
less long-lived
and less invulnerable during the dance
of dragons two Targaryen factions killed
a handful of their families dragons
while fighting each other
a frenzied mob even broke into the
dragon pit and slaughtered the five
dragons chained there
though the last managed to bring down
the roof of the great Dome on its
assailants
the dragons never recovered their former
strength or numbers
perhaps their line had been too broken
or perhaps others intervene to break it
further
but the last dragon grew no larger than
a cat and its death earned aegon third
of his name the epithet Dragon Bay two
years until season two is a long period
but you can still stay in the house of
the Dragon World by listening to Fire
and Blood audiobook for free house of
the Dragon is based on Fire and Blood
book and covers the entire Targaryen
history starting from aegon the
Conqueror and his Conquest as well as
maker the cruel and other legendary
targaryens including the current and
future events of House of the Dragon go
and listen to it for free with horrible
trial using our Link in the description
foreign